it's not just world leaders and
billionaires piling into Davos on the
ground it feels like half the Swiss Army
is here some locals have told me off the
record they're concerned about safety so
is this meeting any different from the
last
no since 9/11 we are always prepared for
the worst-case so also a terrorist
attack is within something we have
prepared I think the the teamwork within
the intelligence community is very good
so we have so far no evidence of no
threat of direct terrorist attack here
in Switzerland Swiss authorities say
around 3,000 personnel are expected to
protect Davos this year
two-thirds supporting the air force
often behind the scenes the town has a
special 46 kilometer no-fly zone should
an unauthorized aircraft enter it the
defense minister has the power to shoot
it down the January 7 Massacre Charlie
Hebdo is office in Paris has led to an
increase in security across Europe in
Davos security measures haven't been
changed there is no direct threat today
it might change in the future
we can't ensure always a hundred percent
security and as long as people are aware
of of that I think the life is going on
for the military it's business as usual
in Davos Tom Gibson Bloomberg